what I'd like to do today is continue
our discussion of supervised learning so
lost Wednesday you saw the linear
regression algorithm including both
gradient descent how poorly the problem
then great in a sense and then the
normal equations what I'd like to do
today is talk about locally weighted
regression which is a way to modify
linear regression to make it fit very
nonlinear functions so you're on just a
straight lines and then we'll talk about
property interpretation of linear
regression and that will lead us into
the first classification algorithm
you've seen this also called logistic
regression and we'll talk about an
algorithm called Newton's method for
logistic regression and so the
dependency of ideas in this class is
that locally weighted regression will
depend on what you learned in linear
regression and then where are you gonna
just cover the key ideas of locally
weighted regression and let you play
some of the ideas yourself in the
problem set one which will release later
this week and then I guess give a
probability interpretation of linear
regression logistic rest on depend on
that and new test method is for logistic
regression
to recap the notation you saw on
Wednesday we use this notation X I comma
iy I to denote a single training example
where X I was n plus 1 dimensional so if
you had two features the size of a house
and the number of bedrooms then X I
would be two plus one repeat
three-dimensional because we had
introduced a new sort of fake feature x0
which was always set to the value of 1
and then why I in the case of regression
is always a real number and was the
number of training examples and was the
number of features and this was the
hypothesis right as the linear function
of the features X including this feature
x0 which is always set to 1 and J was
the cost function you would minimize you
minimizes as function of J to find the
parameter
theta for your straight line fit to the
data okay so that's what you saw last
Wednesday um now if you have a data set
that looks like that where this is the
size of a house and this is the price of
a house what you saw on Wednesday last
Wednesday was an algorithm to fit a
straight line right to this data so the
hypothesis was on the phone theta 0 plus
theta 1 EXO EXO theta 1 x1 right same
thing but with this data set maybe it
actually looks you know maybe the data
looks a little bit like that and so one
question that you have to address when
fitting models to the data is what are
the features you want do you want to fit
a straight line to this problem
or do you want to fit a hypothesis of
the form theta 1x plus theta 2 x squared
since this may be a quadratic function
right now the problem quadratic function
is a quadratic function eventually
starts you know curving back down no
that would be a quadratic function
this starts curving back down so maybe
you don't want to fit a quadratic
function instead maybe you want um it's
a fit
something like that
if housing prices sort of curve down a
little bit but you don't want it to
eventually curve back down the way a
quadratic function weight right
so oh and and if you want to do this the
way you would implement this is you
define the first feature x1 equals x and
the second feature x2 equals x squared
or you define X 1 to be equal to X and X
2 equals square root of x right and by
defining a new feature X 2 which can be
the square of X the square root of x
then the machinery that you solve from
wednesday of linear regression applies
to fit these types of these types of
functions the data
later this quarter you hear about
feature selection algorithms which is a
type of algorithm for automatically
deciding do you want x squared as a
feature or square root of x as a feature
or maybe you want some longer of X as a
feature right but what's other features
does the best job fitting the data that
you have if it's not fit well by a
perfectly straight line what I'd like to
do today is so you hear about feature
selection later this quarter what I want
to share you today is a different way of
accessing this out this problem of one
of the data isn't just fit Y by a
straight line and in particular my share
of you an idea called
a locally weighted regression or locally
weighted linear regression so let me use
a slightly different example to
illustrate this which is which is that
you know if you have a data set that
looks like that so it's pretty clear
what the shape of this data is but how
do you fit a curve that you know kind of
looks like that right and it's actually
quite difficult to find features is it
square root of x log of X X cubed like
third root of X except off 2/3 but what
is the set of features that lets you do
this so well sidestep all those problems
of an algorithm called locally weighted
regression
and so introduce if it will machine
learning terminology in machine learning
we sometimes distinguish between
parametric learning algorithms and non
parametric learning algorithms but in a
parametric learning algorithm there's a
you fit some fixed set of parameters
such as theta I to data and so linear
regression as you saw last Wednesday is
a parametric learning algorithm because
there's a fixed set of parameters the
theta I so you fit the data and then
you're done right locally weighted
regression will be our first exposure to
a nonparametric learning algorithm and
what that means is that the amount of
data / parameters you need to keep
throws and in this case it grows
linearly with the size of the data size
the training set okay so with a
parametric learning algorithm no matter
how big your training your training set
is you fit the parameters stay there I
then you could erase the training set
from your computer memory and make
predictions just using the parameters
data all in a nonparametric learning
algorithm which we'll see in a second
the amount of stuff you need to keep
around in computer memory or the net
amount stuff you need to store around
grows linearly as a function of the
training set size and so this type of
algorithm is you know we may not be
great if you're a really really massive
dataset because you keep all of the data
you're in computer memory or on this
just to make predictions okay so but
we'll see an example of this and one of
the effects of this is that will that it
will be able to fit that data that I
drew up there quite well without you
needing to fiddle manually with features
again you get to practice implementing
locally way to regression that whole
work so I'm going to go for the height
of ideas relatively quickly and then let
you gain practice in the problem set all
right so let me redraw that data set
something like this all right so say you
have a data set like this now for linear
regression if you want to evaluate it at
a certain value of the input so to make
a prediction at a certain value of X
what's you for linear regression what
you do is you fit theta you know to
minimize this cost function and then you
return say the transpose X right so you
for the straight line and then you know
if you want to make a prediction that
this value X you then return say the
transpose X for locally weighted
regression
you do something slightly different
which is if this is the value of
actually you want to make a prediction
around that value of X what you do is
you look in a little local neighborhood
at the training examples close to that
point X we want to make a prediction and
then I'll describe this informally for
now but we'll formalize this in math in
a second but focusing mainly on these
examples and you know looking a little
bit at further examples but really
focusing mainly on these examples you're
trying to fit a straight line like that
focusing on the training examples that
close to where you want to make a
prediction and by close I mean the
values are similar on the x axis the x
values are similar and then to actually
make a prediction you will use this
Green Line there you just fit to make a
prediction at that value of x now if you
want to make a prediction at a different
point let's say that you know the user
now says hey make a prediction for this
point then what you would do is gain
focus on this local area kind of look at
those points and when I say focus saying
you know put most of the weight on these
points but you kind of take a glance at
the points further away but most of the
attention is on these for the straight
lines of that and then you use that
straight line to make a prediction okay
and so to formalize this and locally
weight a regression you will fit theta
to minimize a modified cost function
where WI is a weight function and so a
good well the default choice a common
choice of WI will be this I'm gonna add
something to this equation a little bit
later but WI is a weighting function
where notice that this this formula has
defining property right if X I minus X
is small then the weight will be close
to one because if X I X so X is the
location where you want to make a
prediction and X I is the input X for
your life training example so WI is a
weighting function there's a value which
is 0 and 1 that tells you how much
should you pay attention to the values
of X I comma Y I when fitting say this
green line or that red line and so if X
I minus X is small so that's the
training example that is close to where
you want to make the prediction for X
then this is about e to the zero right e
to the negative 0 if the numerator you
are small and e to the 0 is close to 1
right and conversely if X I minus X is
large then WI it's close to 0 and so if
X is very far away so let's see a
fitting this green line and this is your
example X I Y I then the saying give
this example all the way out there if
your fitting the Green Line right look
at this verse X saying that example
shadow weight very close to 0 ok
and so if you look at the cost function
the main modification to the cost
function with main is that we've added
this weighting term and so what locally
weighted regression does is the same if
an example X I is far from where you
want to make a prediction multiply get
error term by 0 or by a constant very
close to zero whereas if it's close to
where you want to make prediction
multiply the error term by one and so
the net effect of this is that this is
something if you know the terms
multiplied by zero disappear right so
the net effect of this is that this sums
over essentially only the terms for the
squared error for the examples they're
close to the value close to the value of
x where you want to make a prediction
and that's why when you fit theta to
minimize this you end up paying
attention only to the points only to the
examples close to where you wanna make
friction and fitting a line like the
Green Line over there okay so let me
draw a couple more pictures to
illustrate this so if you're slightly
smaller data set just to make this
easier illustrate so that's your
training set so that's the Oh example 6
1 X 2 X 3 X 4 and if you want to make a
prediction here right at that point X
then this curve here looks the the shape
of this curve is actually like this and
it this is the shape of a Gaussian bell
curve but this is nothing to do with a
Gaussian density right so this thing
does not integrate the 1 it's just
sometimes your awesome one is this is
using Gaussian density the answer is no
this is just a function that is shaped a
lot like a Gaussian but you know
Gaussian density is probably the C
functions have to integrate to one and
distance
so there's nothing to do for Gaussian
probably density question oh so how do
you choose well let me get back to that
and so for this example this height here
says if this example a weight equal to
the height to that thing give this
example a way to go height of this
height of this height of that right
which is why if you actually if you have
an example this way out there you know
it's given a weight that's essentially
zero which is why it's waiting or
neither nearby the examples when trying
to fit a straight line right for that
for making predictions close to this
okay um now so one last thing I want to
mention which is the question just now
which is how do you choose the width of
this Gaussian density right how fast is
it how thin should it be
and this decides how big a neighborhood
should you look in order to decide
what's the neighborhood of points that
you use to fit this your local straight
line and so for a Gaussian function like
this this i'm gonna call this the
bandwidth parameter towel and this is a
parameter or hyper parameter of the
algorithm and depending on the choice of
towel you can choose a fatter or thinner
bell-shaped curve which causes you to
look in a bigger or a narrower window in
order to decide you know how many nearby
examples used in order to fit the
straight line okay
and it turns out that and I wonder the I
want to leave you to discover this
yourself in the problem set if if you've
taken a little bit of machine learning
elsewhere I've heard of the terms oh yes
it turns out that um the choice of the
bandwidth towel has an effect on over 15
another fitting if you don't know what
those terms being don't worry about it
to find them later this quarter but what
you get to do in the problem sets is
play with Tao yourself and see why if
tau is too broad you end up fitting your
end up over smoothing the data and if
tau is too thin you end up fitting a
very jagged fit to the data and if any
of these things don't make sense yet
don't worry about it they'll make sense
after you play of it in the in the
problem set okay yeah since since you
you play with the varying tau and the
problem set and see for yourself the net
impact okay thank you this is tau screen
yeah what happens you need to defer the
value of H outside school they said it
turns out that you can still use this
algorithm it's just that it's results
may not be very good yeah
locally within the linear regression is
usually not greater than extrapolation
but then most many learning armors are
not great at extrapolation so all the
formulas still work is so implement is
but um yeah you know also try you can
also try the your problem set and see
what happens yes this is multiple the
variable towel Devon
yes it is and there are quite
complicated ways to choose tau based on
how many points there on the local
region and so on yes there's a huge
literature on different formulas
actually for example it serves as
Gaussian bumping there's a sometimes
people use that triangle shape function
so it happily goes to zero upsides and
small me so there are there are many
versions of this algorithm so I tend to
use locally weighted linear regression
when you have a relatively low
dimensional dataset so when the number
features it's not too big right so when
n is quite
all right two or three or something and
we have a lot of data and you don't want
to think about what features to use
right so that's the scenario so if you
actually a data set that looks like
these up and drawing you know locally
way to the interaction is a pretty good
algorithm oh sure yes the remote data
wanted to accomplish an expensive yes it
would be I guess what data is relative
yes we have you know two three four
dimensional later and hundreds of
examples of many thousand examples it
turns out the computation needed to fit
the minimization is similar to the
normal equations and so you involve
solving a linear system of equations of
dimension equal the number of training
examples you have so that's you know
like a thousand or a few thousand that's
not too bad if you have millions of
examples then then there are also most
of skilled algorithms like KT trees and
much more complicated algorithms to do
this when you have millions or tens of
millions of examples yeah okay so ready
you get a better sense of this algorithm
when you play of it in the problem set
now the second topic when so I'm going
to put aside locally weighted regression
we won't talk about that said ideas
anymore today but but what I want to do
today is on last Wednesday I had said
that I had promised last Wednesday that
today I'll give a justification for why
we use the squared error right why the
squared error why not you know to the
fourth power or absolute value and so
what I want to show you today now is the
promisee interpretation of linear
regression and this properties
interpretation will put us into good
standing as we go on to logistic
regression today and then generalized
any models later this week keep up to
keep the notation there a secure
continue to refer to it
so right so why these squares Y squared
error going to present a set of
assumptions under which these squares
using squared error falls out very
naturally which is let's say for housing
price prediction let's assume that
there's a true price of every house why
I which is X transpose say there I plus
epsilon I where epsilon I is an error
term that includes unmodeled effects you
know and just random noise so let's
assume that the way you know housing
prices truly work is that every houses
price is a linear function of the size
of holes and number of bedrooms plus an
error term they captures unmodeled
effects such as maybe one day that cell
is an unusually good mood or an
unusually bad mood and so that makes the
price go higher or lower
we just don't model that as well as
random noise right or maybe I don't want
to screw this straight
you know percent adjusting caption
that's one of the features but other
things have an impact on housing prices
and we're going to assume that epsilon I
is distributed Gaussian with mean zero
and covariance Sigma squared so I'm
going to use this notation to mean so
the way you read this notation is
epsilon I this turtle new pronoun says
is distributed and then script n for n 0
comma Sigma squared this is a normal
distribution also called the Gaussian
distribution same thing normal in the
Spirit of God students should be in the
same
the normal distribution with mean zero
and variance Sigma squared okay and what
this means is that the probability
density of epsilon I this is the
Gaussian density one of the root 2 Pi
Sigma e to the negative epsilon I
squared over 2 Sigma squared ok oh and
unlike the bell shape the bell-shaped
curve I use earlier for locally weighted
linear regression this thing does
integrate to one right this dysfunction
integrates to 1 and so this is a
Gaussian density this is a probability
density function and this is the
familiar you know Gaussian bell-shaped
curve would mean 0 and covere and
variance Sigma squared right where Sigma
kind of controls the width of this
Gaussian okay and if you haven't seen
gaussians for a while we'll go over some
of the probability probably prereqs as
well in the classes friday and
discussion sections
so in other words we assume that the way
housing prices are determined is that
first is a true price theta transpose X
and then you know some random force of
nature right the move of the seller or I
I don't have other factors right
perturbs it from this true value say
their transpose X I and the huge
assumption we're gonna make is that the
epsilon is these error terms are a ID
and iid from statistics sense for
independently and identically
distributed and what that means is that
their error term for one house is
independent as the error term for a
different house which is actually not a
true assumption right because you know
if if one house this price on one street
is unusually high probably a price on a
different house on the same street will
also be unusually high and so but this
assumption that these epsilonr iid
sensor independently and identically
distributed is one of those assumptions
that that you know it's probably not
absolutely true but may be good enough
that if you make this assumption you get
a pretty good model and so let's see
under the set of assumptions this
implies that the density or the
probability of Y given X I and theta
this is going to be this and I'll take
this and writes in another way in other
words given X and theta
what's the density well what's the
probability of a particular house this
price well it's going to be Gaussian
working in given by theta transpose X I
or theta transpose X and the area is
given by Sigma squared okay
and so because the way that the price of
a house is determined is by thinking
theta transpose X was the you know the
quote true price of the house and then
adding noise or adding error of variance
Sigma squared to it and so the the
assumptions on the left imply that given
X and theta the density of Y you know
has this distribution which is really
this is the random variable Y and that's
the mean that's the variance of the
Gaussian density okay now um two pieces
of notation I have one more that that
you should get familiar with the reason
I wrote the semicolon here is that the
way you read this equation is the
semicolon should be read as a
parameterised ass and so because you
know the alternative way to write this
would be to say P of X are given why I
give Y given X I comma theta but if you
were to write this notation this way
this would be conditioning on theta but
theta is not a random variable so you
shouldn't conditional on theta which is
why I'm gonna write a semicolon and so
the way you read this is the program Y
are given X I and parameterised excuse
me parametrized by theta is equal to
that formula okay if you don't
understand this distinction again don't
worry too much about it in statistics
there are multiple schools of statistics
called Bayesian statistics and
frequencies statistics this is a
frequentist interpretation for the
purpose of machine learning don't worry
about it but I find there being more
consistent terminology
some of our statisticians friends from
getting really upset but you know some
try to follow statistics convention so
because just only unnecessary flag I
guess but for the practical purposes is
not that important if you get this
notation wrong your homework don't worry
about it we won't penalize you but our
child be consistent but this just means
that theta in this view is not a random
variable it's just theta as a set of
parameters that parameterize is this
probably distribution okay and the way
to read the second equation is when you
write these equations usually don't
write down with parentheses but the way
to pause this equation is to say that
this thing as a random variable the
random variable Y given X and
parametrized by theta this thing that I
just drew in green parentheses is this
you take Gaussian with that distribution
okay all right any questions about this
so it turns out that if you are willing
to make those assumptions then the new
regression falls out almost naturally of
the assumptions we just made and in
particular under the assumptions we just
made the likelihood of the parameters
theta so this is pronounced the
likelihood of the parameters theta L of
theta which is defined as the
probability of the data right so this is
probably of all the values of Y of y1 up
to Y M given all the X's and given the
parameters theta a parametrized by theta
this is equal to the product from I
equals 1 through m appear why I even X
my franchise by theta because we assume
the examples were because we assume the
errors are iid right then the error
terms are independently and identity
destroys each other so the probability
of all of the observations of all the
values of Y in our training set is equal
to the product of the probabilities
because of the independence assumption
we made and so plugging in the
definition that P of Y given X franchise
by theta that we had up there this is
equal to product
okay now again one more piece of
terminology
you know another question about mandalas
if you say hey Andrew what's the
difference between likelihood and
probability right and so the likelihood
of parameters is exactly the same thing
as the probability of the data but the
reason we sometimes talk about
likelihood and some to solve a
probability is we think of likelihood so
this is some function right this thing
is a function of the data as well as a
function of the parameters theta and if
we viewed this number whatever this
number is if you view this thing as a
function of the parameters holding the
data fix then we call that the
likelihood so you think of the training
set the data is a fixed thing and then
varying parameters theta then I'm going
to use the term likelihood whereas if
you view the parameters theta as fixed
and maybe varying the data are going to
say probability right so so you hear me
use well I'll try to be consistent I
find I'm pretty good at being consistent
but not perfect but I'm going to try to
say likelihood of the parameters and
probability of the data even though
those evaluate to the same thing it's
just you know for this function this
function is function the data and the
parameters which one that UV leaners
fixing which one are you viewing this is
variable so when you view this as a
function of theta when I use the term
likelihood but so so hopefully you hear
me say likelihood of the parameters
hopefully you won't hear me say
likelihood of the data right and then
similarly hopefully you hear me say
probably the data and not probably of
the parameters
like the Frances okay so probably at the
data no tech got it sorry yes like your
paycheck got it yes sorry yes like a
theory right oh no so no so theta is a
set of parameters it's not a random
variable so we like you of theta
doesn't mean theta is a random variable
right by the way the stuff about what's
a random variable and what's not the
semicolon versus comma thing we explain
this in more detail on the lecture notes
to me this is part of them you know a
little bit paying homage to the to their
religion of Bayesian frequencies versus
Bayesian frequencies versus Bayesian
statistics from from a machine from
apply machine learning operational what
you write code point of view it doesn't
matter that much yeah but theta is not a
random variable we have likely or the
parameters which another random variable
what's the rationale for choosing oh
sure why is epsilon I Gaussian so it
turns out because the central limit
theorem from statistics most error
distribution or Gaussian right if
something is it is an error that's made
up of lots of little noise sources which
are not too correlated and by the
central limit theorem it will be
Gaussian so if you think that hope that
the rotations are the mood in the seller
was the School District
you know what's the weather like access
to transportation and all of these
sources are not too correlated and you
add them up then the distribution will
be Gaussian and and I think yeah
so really because the central limit
theorem I think the gaussians become a
default noise distribution but for
things where the true noise distribution
is very far from Gaussian this model
does do this well and in fact for when
you see generalized linear models on
Wednesday you see when how to generalize
all of these algorithms to very
different distributions like possum and
so on alright so so we've seen the
likelihood of the parameters theta so
I'm going to use lower case L to denote
the log likelihood and the log
likelihood is just a longer the
likelihood and so and so log of a
product is equal to the sum of the logs
right and so this is equal to
okay and so one of the you know well
tested methods in statistics for
estimating parameters is to use maximum
likelihood estimation which means atchoo
Stata to maximize the likelihood right
so you're going to dataset how would you
like to estimate theta
well one natural way to choose theta is
to choose whatever value of theta has
the highest likelihood or in other words
choose the value of theta so that that
value of theta maximizes the probability
of the data and so for to simplify the
algebra rather than maximizing the
likelihood capital L is actually easier
to maximize the log likelihood but the
log is a strictly monotonically
increasing function so the value of
theta that maximizes the log likelihood
it should be the same as the value of
theta that maximizes our likelihood and
if you derived a log likelihood we
conclude that if you're using maximum
likelihood estimation what you'd like to
do is choose the value of theta that
maximizes this thing right but this
first term is just a constant theta
doesn't even appear in this first term
and so what you like to do is choose the
value of theta that maximizes the second
term notice there's a minus sign there
and so what you'd like to do is ie you
know choose theta to minimize this term
right oh so Sigma squared is just a
constant right no matter what Sigma
squared is you know so so so if you want
to minimize this term excuse me if you
want to maximize this term negative of
this thing that's the same as minimizing
this term but this is just J of theta
the cost function you saw earlier for
linear regression okay so this little
proof shows that choosing the value of
theta to minimize the least squares
errors like you saw last Wednesday
that's just finding the maximum
likelihood estimate for the parameters
theta under the set of assumptions we
made that the error terms are Gaussian
and iid okay oh thank you
Oh is there a situation using this phone
as a least-squares cost function with
better idea no so this I think this
derivation shows that this this is
completely equivalent to these squares
right that if you want if you're willing
to assume that the error terms are
Gaussian and iid and if you want to use
maximum likelihood estimation which is
very natural procedure and statistics
then you know then you should use these
squares if you knew for some reason
Arizona idea which figure about the cost
function yes I know I think that you
know when building learning algorithms
often we make maldo we make assumptions
about the world that we just know are
not hunched up sent true because it
leads to algorithms accomplished and
efficient and so if you knew that your
if you knew that your training set was
very very non-id there are there most of
skated modeled as you could build but
yeah but but very often we wouldn't
bother I think ya know more often than
not we might not bother I can think of a
few special cases where you would bother
but only if you think the assumptions
are really really bad if you don't have
enough data and so something waitwait
via alright I want to move on to make
sure we get through the rest of things
any questions all right
so armed with this machinery right so so
what do we do here was we set up a set
of problems occur some shion's we made
certain assumptions about P of Y given X
where the key assumption was Gaussian
errors in IIT and then through maximum
likelihood estimation we derived an
algorithm which turns out to be exactly
the least squares algorithm right what
I'd like to do is take this framework
and apply it
our first classification problem right
and so the key steps are you know one
make an assumption about P of Y given X
P of Y given X parameter
in a second is figure out maximum
likelihood estimation it's nice to take
this framework and apply it to a
different type of problem where the
value of y is now either zero or one
size of your classification problem okay
so let's see so in the classification
problem in our first classification
problem we're going to start with binary
classification so the value of y is
either 0 or 1
and sometimes we call this binary
classification because there are two
classes and so so that's a data set
where yes this is X and this is y um so
something that's not a good idea is
applied linear regression to this data
set some sometimes we will do it and
maybe they get away with it but I
wouldn't do it and here's why
which is um it's tempting to just fit a
straight line to this data and then take
the straight line and threshold it at
0.5 and then say oh if this is above 0.5
rounds after 1 it is below 0.5 rends it
off to 0 but it turns out that this is
not a good idea for classification
problems and here's why which is for
this data set it's really obvious what
the what the pattern is right everything
to the left at this point for the 0 I
think the right at that point for the
good one but let's say we now change the
data set to just add one more example
there and the pattern is still really
obvious is everything to the left of
this breathing zero
I think it's right of that for the good
one but they fit a straight line to this
data set with this extra one point there
and just not even the outlier it's
really obvious at this point way out
there should be labeled one but was this
extra example if you fit a straight line
to the data you end up with maybe
something like that and somehow having
this one example it really didn't change
anything right but somehow the string I
fit
from the green lines of the move from
the blue line to the green line and if
you now flash hold it at 0.5 you end up
with a very different decision boundary
and so linear regression is just not a
good algorithm for classification some
people use it and sometimes again lucky
is not too bad but I personally never
used the neighbor aggression for
classification algorithms right because
just don't know if you end up with a
really bad fit to the data like this um
so oh and and and the other unnatural
thing about using linear regression for
classification problem is that you know
for a classification problem that the
values are you know 0 or 1 right and so
it's output negative values or values
even greater than 1 seems seems strange
so what I'd like to share of you now is
really probably by far the most commonly
used classification algorithm called
logistic regression I always say the two
learning are rooms I probably use the
most often on linear regression and
logistic regression yeah yeah and this
is the algorithm so as we designed in
logistic regression algorithm one of the
things we might naturally want is for
the hypothesis to output values between
0 & 1
right and this is mathematical notation
for the values for H of X or H prime H
subscript theta of X lies in the set
from 0 to 1 right the 0 to 1 square
bracket is the set of all real numbers
from 0 to 1 so this is we want the
hypothesis output values in between 0
and 1 in the set of all numbers which is
from 0 to 1 and so we're going to choose
the following form of the hypothesis so
so will it define the function G of Z
that looks like this and this is called
the sigmoid or the logistic function
these are synonyms they mean exactly the
same thing so can we call the sigmoid
function or the logistic function it
means exactly the same thing but I'm
gonna choose a function G of Z and this
function is shaped as follows if you
plot this function you find that it
looks like this where if the horizontal
axis is Z then this is G of Z and so it
crosses x intercept at 0 and it you know
starts off well really close to 0 Rises
and then asymptotes towards 1 okay and
so G of Z outputs values between 0 and 1
and what logistic regression does is
instead of let's see so previously for
linear regression we had chosen this
form for the hypothesis right we just
made a choice that will say that housing
prices are a linear function of the
features X and what logistic regression
does is say the transpose X could be
bigger than 1 it could be less than 0
which is not very natural but it's gonna
take theta transpose X and pass it
through this sigmoid function G so this
force the output values only between 0
and 1 ok so you know when designing a
learning algorithm sometimes you just
have to choose the form of the
hypothesis how are you going to
represent the function H or H of H
subscript theta and so we're making that
choice here today and if you're
wondering you know there are lots of
functions that we could have chosen
right there loss of why why not why not
dysfunction or why not you know there
lots of functions with very the shape to
go but easier and
so why are we choosing this specifically
it turns out that there's a broader
class of algorithms called generalized
any models you hear about on Wednesday
of which this is a special case so we've
seen linear Russian you see logistic
regression in a second
and on Wednesday you see that both of
these examples of a much bigger set of
algorithms derive using a broader set of
principle so so for now just you know
take my word for it that we want to use
the logistic function it'll turn out you
see on Wednesday that this way to derive
even dysfunction from from more basic
principles rather than just putting all
this does that happen for now let me
just pull this out of a hat and say
that's the one we want to use
so let's make some assumptions about the
distribution of Y given X franchise by
theta so I'm going to assume that the
data has a following distribution the
probability of Y being 1 again from the
breast cancer prediction that we had
from the first lecture right it would be
the chance of a tumor being cancerous of
being malignant chance of Y be new one
given the size of a tumor that's the
future x parametrized by theta that this
is equal to the output of your
hypothesis so in other words going
assume that what you want your learning
algorithm to do is input the features
and tell me what's the chance that this
tumor is malignant right what's the
chance that Y is equal to one and by
logic I guess because Y can be only one
or zero the chance of Y being equal to
zero this has got to be one minus that
right because if a tumor has a 10%
chance of being malignant that means it
has a 1 minus that means it must have a
90% chance of being benign right since
these two probabilities must add up to
one
I'll say it again
oh can we change Peru
yes you can but I'm not yet but I think
just a stick of convention in the
z-direction you yeah sure because assume
that P of y equals 1 was this in P of y
equals 1 was that but I think either way
it's just what you call positive example
why you call negative example um and now
bearing in mind that Y right by
definition because it's a binary
classification problem but bearing in
mind that Y can only take on two values
0 1 there's a nifty so the algebra way
to take these 2 equations and write them
in one equation and this will make some
of the math a little bit easier when I
take these two equations take these two
assumptions and take these two facts and
compress it into one equation which is
this oh and I dropped the theta
subscript just to simplify the notation
I'm gonna be a little bit sloppy
sometimes well no less one more whether
I write the theta there okay but these
two definitions appear Y given X
paralyzed by theta bear in mind that Y
is either 0 one can be compressed into
one equation like this and then just say
Y right is because if y
if one is equal to one then this becomes
H of X to the power of one times this
thing it's a power of zero right if Y is
equal to 1 then 1 minus y is 0 and you
know anything so the power of 0 is just
equal to 1 and so if Y is equal to 1 you
end up with P of Y given X prioritize by
theta equals H of X which is just what
we had there and conversely if Y is
equal to 0 then this thing will be 0 and
this thing would be 1 and so you end up
with P of Y given X perilous theta is
equal to 1 minus H of X which is just
equal to that second equation ok right
and so this is a nifty way to take these
two equations and compress them into one
line because depending on whether Y is
zero one one of these two terms switches
off because it's exponentiated to the
power of zero and anything to the power
of zero is just equal of one right so
one of these terms is just you know one
doesn't leaving the other term and just
selecting the appropriate equation
depend on whether Y is zero one okay so
with that so with this little on a
notational trick you'll make the later
derivations simpler
so all right she can reuse along with
this all right so we're gonna use
maximum likelihood estimation again so
let's write down the likelihood of the
parameters so it's actually PF otherwise
given all the XS for entrance by theta
which is equal to this which is now
equal to product from I equals 1 through
X KY ^ Y I times 1 minus H of X I - why
okay where all I did was take this
definition of P of Y given X parent
choice by theta you know from that after
we did that little exponentiation trick
and wrote it in here
and then what maximum likelihood
estimation we'll want to find the value
of theta that maximizes the likelihood
maximize the likelihood of the
parameters and so same as what we did
for linear regression to make the
algebra yeah to make the out you're a
bit more simple we're going to take the
log of the likelihood and so compute the
log likelihood and so that's equal to
let's see right I say if you take the
log of that you end up with and it so so
in other words the last thing you want
to do is try to choose the value of
theta to try to maximize L of theta now
so just just to summarize where we are
right if you're trying to predict your
malignancy in bananas of tumors you have
a training set with X I Y I you define
the likelihood to find a log likelihood
and then what you need to do is have an
algorithm such as gradient descent
agreed innocent talk about that a sec to
try to find the value of theta that
maximizes the log likelihood and then
having chosen the value of theta when a
new patient walks into the doctor's
office you would you know take the
features of the new tumor and then use H
of theta to estimate the chance of this
new tumor and the new patient that walks
in tomorrow's estimate the chance that
this new thing is this malignant
okay so the algorithm were going to use
to choose theta to try to maximize the
log likelihood is gradient ascent or
batch gradient ascent and what that
means is we will update the parameters
theta J according to theta J plus the
partial derivative with respect to the
log-likelihood okay and the differences
from what you saw for linear regression
from last time it's the following just
two differences I guess for linear
regression last week I have written this
down theta J gets updated as theta J
minus partial with respect to theta J of
J of theta right so you saw this on
Wednesday so the two differences between
dances are well first instead of J of
theta you're now trying to optimize the
log likelihood instead of the squared
cost function and the second change is
previously you were trying to minimize
the squared error that's why we had the
minus and today you're trying to
maximize the log likelihood which is why
there's a plus sign okay and so so great
in E sent you know it's trying to climb
down this hill whereas gradient ascent
has a has a concave function like this
and it's trying to write climb up the
hill
rather than climb down their goal so
that's why there's a plus symbol here
instead of a minus because we maximize
the function rather than minimize the
function so the last thing to really
flesh out this algorithm which is done
in the lecture notes but I don't want to
do to you today is to plug in the
definition of H of theta into this
equation and then take this thing so
that's the log likelihood of theta and
then through you know calculus and
algebra you can take derivatives of this
whole thing with respect
theta this is done in detail in the
lecture notes I don't want to use it
cost but go ahead and take the Ritter's
at this big formula with respect to the
parameters theta in order to figure out
what is that thing right what is this
thing that I just circled and it turns
out that if you do so you will find that
batch gradient descent is the following
you update theta J according to actually
I'm sorry I forgot the learning rate
yeah it's relearning the Alpha learning
rate alpha times this because this term
here is the partial derivative respect
to theta J and the full calculus and so
on derivation is given in the lecture
notes is a chance of local Maxima in
this case no there isn't
it turns out that this function that the
log-likelihood function o of theta for
logistic regression that always looks
like that so this is a concave function
so there are no local op that the only
maximum as a global Maxima there's
actually another reason why we chose the
logistic function because if you choose
the logistic function rather than some
other function reserve the one you're
guaranteed that the likelihood function
has only one global maximum and this
there's actually a big positive actually
what you see on Wednesday this is a big
class of algorithms
I wish linear regression is one example
which is addresses another example and
for all of these algorithms in this
class there are no local Optima problems
when you when you derived them this way
so you see that on Wednesday wouldn't
talk about us
okay so actually I think your bun is
just one question for you to think about
this looks exactly the same as what
we've paid it out for linear regression
right actually the difference the linear
regression was I had a minus sign here
and I reversed these two terms I think
there's a big sign - weii if you put the
minus sign there and reverse these two
terms so take the minus - this is
actually exactly the same as when we had
come up with a linear regression so why
is this different right I started off
saying don't use the knee regression for
classification problems because of
because of that problem that a single
example could really you know I'm sorry
I start off with an example saying that
linear regression is really bad for
classification and we did all this work
and came back to the same algorithm so
what happened all right cool awesome
right so what happened is the definition
of H of theta is now different than
before but the surface level the
equation turns out to be the same okay
and again it turns out that for every
algorithm and discourse around as you
see on Wednesday you end up with the
same thing actually there's a general
property of a much bigger class of
algorithms called generalize many models
although yeah interesting historical
divergence because of the confusion
between these two algorithms in the
early history of machine learning there
was some debate about a Oh between
academia saying no I invented that no I
invented that
no is actually different algorithms all
right any questions
oh great question is their equivalents
of normal equations to logistic
regression short answer is no so for
linear regression the normal equations
gives you like a one-shot way to just
find the best value of theta there is no
known way to just have a closed form
equation unless you find the best value
of theta which is why you always have to
use an algorithm in sort of optimization
out rooms such as creating ascend or and
we'll see in a second Newton's method
cool
so there's a great lead-in to the lost
topic for today which is Mutants method
um you know created in a sense right
it's a good algorithm I use screen to
send all the time but it takes the baby
step takes a baby sir taking the baby
set takes a lot of iterations for
gradient ascent to converge there's
another algorithm called Newton's method
which allows you to take much bigger
jumps to let's data you know so there
are problems where you might need
they'll say a hundred iterations or a
thousand iterations are great in ascent
that if you run this algorithm called
Newton's method you might need only ten
iterations to get a very good value of
theta but each iteration will be more
expensive we talked about pros and cons
a second
but um let's see how let's let's
describe this algorithm which is
sometimes much faster for gradient than
great innocent for optimizing the value
of theta okay so um what we'd like to do
is so let me let me use the simplify one
dimensional problem to describe Newton's
method so I'm going to solve a slightly
different problem with Newton's method
which is say you have some function f
and you want to find theta such that f
of theta is equal to zero okay so this
is a problem that Newton's method solves
and the way we're going to use this
later is what you really want is to
maximize L of theta right and well at
the maximum the first derivative must be
zero so ie
you want to value where the derivative L
prime of theta is equal to zero right
and L prime is the derivative of theta
because this is L prime is another
notation for the first derivative theta
so you want to maximize the function or
minimize the function whether
Muse's you want to find a point where
the derivative is equal to zero
so the way we're going to use Newton's
method is we're going to set f of theta
equal to the derivative and then try to
find the point where the derivative is
equal to zero okay but to explain your
tennis method I'm gonna you know work on
this other problem where you have a
function f and you just want to find the
value of theta where f of states is
equal to zero and then it will set F
equal to L prime theta and that's how we
will apply this to logistic regression
so let me draw in pictures how this
algorithm works
all right so let's say that's the
function f and you know to make this
drawable on a whiteboard I'm gonna
assume theta is just a real number for
now so theta is just a single you know
like a scalar a real number so this is
how Newton's method works oh and the
goal is to find this point right
the goal is to find the value of theta
with F of theta is equal to zero okay so
let's say you start off from let's see
you start off at this point right at the
first iteration you know randomly I stay
there and nationally thing is zero
something but let's say you start up at
that point this is how one iteration of
Newton's method will work which is start
off with theta zero that's just the
first value first iteration what we're
going to do is look at the function f
and then find a line that's just tangent
to F so take the derivative of F and
find a line that's just tangent to F so
take that red line there this just
touches a function f and we're going to
use if you will use the straight line
approximation to F and solve for where F
touches the horizontal axis so we're
gonna solve for the point where this
straight line touches the horizontal
axis okay and then we're going to set
this and that's one iteration of
Newton's method so they're going to move
from this value to this value and then
in the second iteration of Newton's
method we're gonna look at this point
and again you know take a line that's
just tangent to it and then solve for
where this touches the horizontal axis
and then that's after two iterations of
u2's men right and then you repeat take
this sometimes you can overshoot a
little bit but that's okay right
and then that so
it gives us a cycle back to rent that
stay the three then you take this
let's stay there for so you can tell
that Tom Newton's method it's actually
pretty fast algorithm right within just
what one two three four iterations we've
gotten really really close to the point
where F of theta is equal to zero so
let's write out the map for how you do
this so let's see I'm going to so let me
just write out and derive you know how
you go from theta 0 to theta 1 so I'm
going to use this horizontal distance
I'm gonna denote this as Delta this
triangle is upper case Greek alphabet
Delta right this is lower case Delta
that's upper case Delta right and then
the height here well that's just f of
theta 0 this is the height it's just F
of theta 0 and so let's see
so what we'd like to do is solve for the
value of Delta because one iteration of
Newton's method is a set you know theta
one is set to theta zero minus Delta
right so how do you solve for Delta well
from calculus we know that the slope of
the function f is the height over the
run right height over the width and so
we know that the derivative of del F
prime that's the derivative of F at the
point stay to zero that's equal to the
height that's F of theta divided by the
horizontal right so the derivative
meaning the slope of the red line is by
definition of derivatives is this ratio
between just height over this width and
so Delta is equal to f of theta 0 over F
prime of theta 0 and if you plug that in
then you find that a single iteration of
Newton's method is the following group
data T plus 1 gets updated as theta t
minus f of theta t over F prime of theta
T ok where instead of 0 1 I replaced it
with T and T plus 1 and finally to you
know the very first thing we did was
let's let F of theta be equal to say L
prime of theta right because we want to
find the place where the first
derivative of L is 0 then this becomes
theta T plus 1 gets updated as theta T
minus L prime of theta T over L double
prime of theta T so it's really the
first derivative divided by the second
so
Newton's mess is a very fast algorithm
and it has Newton's method and Joy's
property called quadratic convergence
not a great name don't worry don't worry
too much about what it means but the
informative what it means is that if on
one innovation Newton's method is 0.01
error so on the x-axis you're 0.01 away
from the from the value from from the
true minimum of a true value of F is
zero zero after one iteration the error
could go to zero point zero zero zero
one error and all the two iterations it
goes to zero but roughly Newton's method
under certain assumptions that function
is smooth not too far from quadratic the
number of significant digits that you
have converts the minimum doubles on a
single iteration so this is called
quadratic convergence and so when you
get near the minimum Newton's method
converges extremely rapidly right so so
after a single iteration becomes much
more accurate enumeration becomes way
way way more accurate which is why
Newton's method requires relatively few
innovations and let's see I have written
out Newton's method for when theta is a
real number when theta is a vector
then the generalization of the rule I
wrote above is the following
theta T plus one gets updated as theta T
plus h that where X is the Hessian
matrix so these details are written in
lecture notes but to give you a sense it
when theta is a vector this is a vector
of derivatives it says I guess this part
n plus 1 dimensional if nature is an RN
plus 1 then this derivative respect to
theta of the log-likelihood becomes a
vector of derivatives and the Hessian
matrix this becomes in matrixes are n
plus 1 by n plus 1 so becomes a square
matrix with the dimension equal to the
parameter vector theta and the Hessian
matrix is defined as the matrix of
partial derivatives right so and so the
disadvantage of Newton's method is that
in high dimensional problems if theta is
a vector that each step of Newton's
method is much more expensive because
you're either solving a linear system
craisins or having to convert to pretty
big matrix so if theta is 10 dimensional
you know this involves inverting a 10 by
10 matrix which is fine but if theta was
10,000 or 100,000 then each innovation
requires computing like a hundred
thousand by a hundred thousand matrix
and inverting that which is very hard
it's very very difficult to do that in
very high dimensional problems so you
know some rules of thumb if the number
of parameters you have foolish if the
number of parameters religion aggression
is not too big if you have 10 parameters
or 50 parameters I would almost
certainly I would very likely use
Newton's method
then you probably get convergence in
maybe ten iterations or you know 15
iterations or even less than ten
generations but they've a very large
number of parameters if you have you
know ten thousand parameters then rather
than dealing over 10,000 by 10,000
matrix or even bigger than 55,000 about
50,000 matrix under 50,000 parameters I
would use great in the sentence then
okay but if the number of parameters is
not too big so that the computational
cost per iteration is manageable
then Newton's method converges in a very
small number of iterations and could be
much faster algorithm than gradient
descent all right so that's it Newton's
method on Wednesday this remaining time
on Wednesday you hear about generosity
models I think unfortunately I promised
to be in Washington DC tonight I guess
through Wednesday so you hear from some
I think onion will give the lecture on
Wednesday but I will be back next week
unfortunately what's time to do this but
because of this pulse take on lecture so
so thanks everyone
I always say